you made it you made it you made it all
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this is
the return return return return I don't
know what number return this is for
mosha Casher but I do know it is one of
my all-time favorite episodes ever he is
a delight we had such a fun time he has
a new book out now called subculture
vulture you should check that out check
out anything mosha is doing he's always
just such a reliable joy and we had such
a fun time I should mention we recorded
this a few days ago and it was before
any news came out about Steven Hawking I
don't even know the details of that
Epstein list or whatever but there's
some riffs in here that you'll be like
why aren't they talking about that cuz
you know we love talking about stepen
Hawking uh and it's cuz we didn't know
yet so that's why it can't we recorded
this before any of that news which I'm
still not familiar with but there you go
just wanted to say that up top I'm going
to be at Largo on January 30th this
month largo-la
docomo a theater in Los Angeles once a
month every month so just go to largo-la
outcom and look for Pete Holmes living
at Largo always the highlight of my
month always so fun to have weirdos
there I'm also going to be doing the uh
Netflix is a joke Fest on May 4th May
the 4th be with you and please be with
me in Los Angeles go to P homes.com for
tickets to that also Chicago also in may
not too much to plug if you like the
show and you want to support it why not
try a pizza pick like element I've been
giving so many of my friends elements
it's wonder what is element it's a
hydration super power basically because
healthy hydration isn't just about
drinking water it's water plus
electrolytes and that's what lmnt
element is it's incredible in the
morning Dr Andrew hberman promotes
drinking a a salty water in the morning
to get that neuroconnectivity going to
jump start your day that's when I drink
my element not only does it give you
magnesium and potassium and salt that
you need to get that hydration into your
cells but it also tastes fantastic which
also leads to drinking more water and
feeling better element is been a huge
part of my wellness program I give it to
friends who exercise they drink it after
a jog they say it basically floods them
with everything that they just sweat out
I of course drink it after I work out or
after I sauna but I also just drink it
after a flight anytime that I'm in a
situation that I know dehydrated me and
I want to flood that into me I drink it
before shows cuz there's nothing about
there's nothing better than that Rush of
the Magnesium the potassium and the salt
that just gives your body what it needs
hydration is so so much more than just
drinking water get lmnt into your life I
love their watermelon salt flavor I also
love their chocolate salt flavor which I
drink hot at night sometimes I often
find if you drink it before bed I don't
get up to pee something about the salt
processing the water I can't explain it
I absolutely love it it is a game Cher
and if element doesn't exceed your
expectations they have a no questions
asked refund policy you don't even need
to send it back and they came up with a
fantastic offer for us go to drink
lnt.com weird use promo code weird
you'll get a free element sample pack
with any order which I love because you
can try all the different flavors some
of them are spicy which I really love
some of them are more sweet like the
watermelon that's my daily go to drink
element.com weird use promo code weird
support your body support healthy
hydration and support the show we're
also brought To Us by our friends at the
open app if you're like me you've always
been out there looking for the secrets
to success which is really just another
way of saying how can we overcome the
problems that so many of us face in our
daily lives problems like sleep stress
focus and for me setting up maintaining
daily healthy habits this is the secret
obviously but we sometimes need help and
I found that in the open app I recently
discovered this wonderful tool if you'd
like me you've tried it all trendy diets
books even bad things like drawing the
blinds taking an edible and watching bad
movies all day avoidance is not the
solution it took me years to find a
better way and now I'm passing it on to
you the open method is simple and it
works it combines breath work meditation
and fitness and they have a badass
community of people doing it all
together they're all committed to
personal growth so you have that
accountability and that Community to
join open is the only thing I do every
day that sets me up for success I
usually do the breath work in the
morning makes me feel more focused than
coffee floods your body with just like
Good Life Energy and dials you in the
breath work it's so fun to do but I need
that guidance I need that help and the
open app is wonderful at that I also do
their nighttime meditation before bed
and I fall asleep in under 10 minutes
every time if it was just that it would
be awesome but it's so much more and the
fitness and the community it's
incredibly welld designed you'll know
when you see it my only regret is not
starting sooner to app will change your
life so if you want to get on my daily
routine you can get 30 days free of open
by visiting with
open.com weird again 30 days free by
visiting with open.com weird oh and if
you're in La make sure you check out
their new studio to practice with open
in person support your body support your
breath support your Fitness support your
life and support the show all right
everybody get into mosha Casher and
check out subculture vulture available
now get into
it
mush Mushy Mushy Mushy mushh Mushy mushh
Mushy Mushy you smell good thanks that
looks awesome oh thanks
man modern mammals no modern mammals is
the best shampoo there is I'm excited to
try it that's for you oh really but let
we can put this in front of the modern M
as long as we say we're doing it they
don't pay for that that's just your gift
um I'm excited you really are going to
like it have you heard me talk about it
no I honestly I have not no I've heard
you talk about um bracelet that zap you
do zap you doesn't it buzz you you can
feel it it's on right now see barely
nothing barely it isn't even doing
anything it's not on oh you have and I
heard you talk about um I'm going to
turn it on another a beverage magic mine
it's right there it's for you see I know
I know my home I really appreciate it
merch trivia I was going to research you
and then I realized it's your book
you're going to research me well I was I
called you last night and I meant to say
you know I forgot I didn't for forget
but I I wasn't I did
forget you forgot what just said I was
coming but here's the passive voice no
no I I wasn't quite clear on why now
we're doing another pod and it's because
of the book I I I remembered but I
couldn't read it because it's not on
audio yet oh I should have just sent oh
do you only audio no no no it's not that
I only audio but if I have a guest
promoting a book you know it's like 90
minutes to come in I'll listen to it for
90 minutes you'd be shocked I know
you're a host how much you can get out
of 90 minutes the first 90 minutes of
somebody's book you're an expert at that
book that's fair although I will say
you're very good at talking about that
book go ahead I will say this um first
of all you made it weird as a long
podcast right we can say that that's not
sacrilege to say you guys go longer oh I
I don't understand than an hour of
course yeah okay I got great news we
have I'm here I have the book yeah I'll
just go ahead and read the first 90
minutes of the book I mean honestly the
sound equipment you've got I didn't even
see the Riff coming I didn't see it
coming put it the put the Random House
side out but I but I was going to say
this book uh of of many comedians books
you perhaps don't know all there is to
know about after 90 minutes after 90
minutes well 90 minutes is I bet how
long is this read have you done the
audio yet I have done the audio you can
leave it like that I like that you like
it a Kimbo the pen um a
Kimbo because this is the book is um a
memoir in six scenes that's the subtitle
right and it goes through it does say
that oh there it is a memoir in six
scenes and here you are is what you as a
Japanese anime I'm so shocked as a as a
new age afficionado as a rasian even a
robian no I love this I shouldn't tease
no but I forgot that it's kind of
vulnerable picking a cover this is great
I just went into riff mode you're just
very cleaned up here it's sh Shiva it's
Shiva herself shiva's dice game wait is
Shiva or her Shiva is a I always get it
wrong actually so don't don't ask me I
think shiva's a woman well we've got a
billion people that will write in and
tell us if we're wrong but yeah that's
true she it it is me holding reaching
into each of the six universes that have
created the meanness well that's
interesting is that there's the Buddhist
five wheel is that is that it's not
connected to that although maybe
subconsciously maybe unconsciously so
there's let me see if I can interpret
the cover yeah R you be not even RI
cuz I I honestly forgot how vulnerable
it is to pick a cover or to write a book
just to write a book to put out a cover
I came at it with the wrong energy to me
I I didn't take it that way no I know
but I I was checking myself rarely seen
before I wrecked myself well no yeah
usually right after PR wreck yourself
the prere yourself wow I didn't even wow
that's a rare sighting the prre yourself
is a prerequisite for a good interview
but you know who is prone to
pre-checking oneself before we PR wreck
oneself tell me a comedy sex god what
that's sort of their their I would say
their primary characteristic is that
they check themselves I do have very
mild like the flavor of cilantro and
guacamole okay that much regret
sometimes I wish I called I sometimes
wish I'm going to pitch it to you yeah
okay what if I had called it cuz you
know there's that trend of blank and
blank and blank and blank I sometimes
wish I called it comedy and sex and God
like funny that you're saying and too
many times comedy oh I am a big fan of
the uh mouthful of a title comedy and
sex and God um I I know I just like over
I like a big overe explanation my first
book's title was Casher and the Ry the
true tale of a white boy from Oakland
who became a drug addict criminal mental
patient and turned second album that was
the homage now I didn't I didn't do the
Buddhist Five Points of whatever but I
did do Fiona Apple second uh album yeah
that that's the esotera you're into um
comedy and sex and God I think they are
they Lal sixes we yeah I think that is
what you say it's my favorite writer
room term speaking of sixes sixes means
six of six of one half a dozen of
another but you just say sixes speaking
of sixes this is six scenes let's see if
you can identify them by iconography
only absolutely um well you love music
and psychedelic or well that that looks
more like ecstasy than a psychedelic
this is good the clues are coming in
wait you didn't guess what what is the
what's the scene what do you mean by a
scene that's your Rave scene yes good
ding um CC close oh DEA the de scene the
de scene you I'm big in the de scene
you're huge I've been yes yeah yeah yeah
I'm an honorary Big Time honorary M of
the search your name because I did
because I just wanted to make sure you
didn't have a new special or something
because I would have watched it the the
questions that come up on Google oh boy
no it's funny it's okay good yes who
wrote Casher in the Ry and I'm filled
with internet Delight because I'm like
it's in it's in it's you're halfway
there I'll tell you what I think it is
who wrote cashier in the R I think I
who's in Being John
malovic I honestly think it's a JD
Salinger problem I remember when my book
first came out I went into a Barnes &
Noble to pick up a box of books to sell
at the I was at a comedy club next door
to a Barnes & Noble in I think St Louis
and um Pittsburgh no it Pittsburgh I
know that the listeners were like where
was it and it was Pittsburgh and I went
in and I I go hey I'm here to pick up a
book uh a box of uh cash the book Casher
and the Ry and the the woman behind the
counter goes I love that book and I go I
wrote that book and she like she goes JD
you wrote Catcher in The Ry so I think
that's the issue yeah we both have books
with some confusion Factor baked in
what's yours that people think I'm
calling myself a comedy sex you just did
it I see I see I see that is the joke
the joke is cuz I said to my editor I
was like people are going to think I'm
saying Pete Holmes comedy sex god like
that sounds like a Russell Brand I know
Scandal noted but it sounds like
something he would is that how you do it
now Scandal you say Scandal noted I
thought we we talked about that didn't
we I don't know but I I I feel like you
were one of the people that were like
I'm going to do that because it takes
too long to be like I understand and I
hereby acknowledge I unpack the sins of
the past um and and all kidding aside
it's a nice way to be like I'm in the
same reality we all are Scandal noted I
like that doesn't feel like it gives as
much um um H to as people want I agree
and that makes it funny yes it's kind of
like being like rest in Pace you know
what I mean it's not may his name be
blessed what's that may his name be
blessed may his name be blessed may his
name be blotted from The Book of Life
that's what we should say may their name
be blotted from the book of life but I
don't I don't you don't want to blot
Russell br's name for can I just ask you
one question and I know this is your
podcast is Russell Brand question would
you like Russell Bran's name to be
blotted from The Book of Life that
that's I what my what we just cut to
color bar
like what if I I was flooded with panic
like there's no right way to answer this
it's the ESPN
theme that is so it's the ACT break yeah
we'll be right back it zooms in on my
beating sweat and then when you come
back it's just Russell Brand
here our guest today all right if you're
Russell
Brand completely scandal-free question
okay you going as H Captain Jack Sparrow
for Halloween just getting a big coat
are you dressing up as Captain Jack
Sparrow a big coat away from a rocking
Captain Jack Sparrow this does feel like
a riff from before Scandal not this is a
pre Scandal this is not a good
area Princess D walks up and talks about
the landmines that are all over this
area let me just ask you this if you're
Woody Allen are you dressing as a
private investigator for Halloween
you're just a hat and a trench coat away
that is A+ that is
A+ that is A+ you could have gone nerd
yes you went private eye which is better
a 1970s private eye yeah yeah yeah
classic I'd want Woody on the case not
his own case no he definitely actually
to be honest he got really involved in
his own case I know hey anyway I'm I got
a book coming out de the de World de the
deaf world I am going as R okay good
good no I'm not going as Russell Russell
If I were never mind that would be Pete
let me just say if you dressed as
Russell Brand for Halloween yes I
wouldn't know how to analyze you yeah
that would be a very confusing I would
text my friends about it did you hear
Pete dressed up as Russell Brand for
there's there's something alluring about
that I'm never going to do it but it
makes me happy that the world still has
choices that are pretty benign you know
it's not that hurtful but it's hurtful
it's wrong but it reminds me that the
world can still be completely insane
like you know like the feeling of jelly
in your shoe just weird and what I'm
saying is I would never do it I do kind
of wish I would do it for you uh the fun
for you to be at a Halloween party and
be like is Pete Russell well it's
actually like that weird feeling you'd
get it's a funny riff that you um I
definitely think we should get off this
topic but it's a funny riff that you uh
mention Princess D because I just
watched the last that's and the guy
dressed up as uh oh I haven't seen the
last one well it's it's in the news what
do you mean it happened a long time ago
no I know but like Nate baret's bit
where he's like I know I don't know
anything about history CU whenever I
watch a historical movie I'm on the edge
of my seat I watched that going like
they were in the car together like I
don't know anything well Prince Willie
our boy will actually our neighbor he
lives in he lives really up there oh um
he dressed as a uh as a Nazi on
Halloween one year I thought that was
Prince Harry yeah that guy him Harry I
always I truly have never been able to
tell them apart the redhead hapsburgs
have always confused me hapsburgs aren't
they hapsburgs can I give you my hot
Crown riff yeah it's a whole family of
first ladies uhuh doesn't that help you
understand it like America's so confused
what is the royal family it's like their
first ladies I'm not trying to diminish
first ladies but it's like celebrity
it's charity it's appearances there's no
like signing bills or like starting Wars
but there's political life in the same
way that Michelle Obama you know what I
mean it's it's it's 30 Michelle Obama in
a very nice house do you think we would
be a better off country if we had a
royal
family I think what's great about it and
I I'm really not like a a [__] Giver
about the royal family but what's great
about it is human beings make meaning
right yeah and like we do it with comedy
all the time it's sacred there's a way
to do it there's a right way to do it
almost like in the way that like artists
study under other visual artists study
under them and then they're minted like
we have that like he opened for them he
did the thing and and that gives a
richness to the comedy world that we
enjoy right and it like a hobby like a
very rich Hobby and in the same way a
royal family gives a national identity
that's more Rich deeper more to play
with we just have yeah go that's sort of
the thing I think people miss about
about royalty I mean the problem with
royalty uh is that it has been used
exclusively almost exclusively in the
modern era it's more what you're saying
but in history it's been used
exclusively to essentially say you are
going to be the poor people from time in
Memorial we will take the fat fruit of
your labor and the fat of your land and
we'll come rich and you'll get poorer
and poorer right but you're right that I
think one of the primary diseases thank
you I think one of the could you do that
on let me just start the book subculture
vulture by mosha Casher a memoir in six
scenes I think one of the primary
diseases of America is our uh our our
sort of horrifying lack of ritual and I
agree and there the the primary thing
that we tell immigrants to do by the way
that's like Pledge of Allegiance I'm not
crazy about it but at least we had you
like it a little bit what I'm I'm saying
what I liked about cuz I remember
feeling uncomfortable doing it atol felt
uncomfortable yeah just being weird no
one was doing it and when I first
started public school I was excited to
do it yeah and they're like please stand
for the Pledge of Allegiance no one
stood up oh you went to private school
and never did it never did it went to
public school and was like here we go
yeah I want a flapping flag I'd like to
believe in something that's how I felt
the first time I went to a non-jewish
wedding the the the priest goes or
whoever goes do you Pete take this woman
to be your and I go they're doing it
this is the thing this is the thing I've
seen this in so many movies not just
saying this the Jewish tradition is
lapping it is laping oh is better I have
yeah lapped like a race going the right
way yeah the Jewish wedding ceremony is
I would say one of our best calling
cards your wedding we had to go because
of a a Val wasn't feeling well she had
like a I thought you me you had to go to
the wedding no no no we had to leave but
I did get to see the caner and the the
chairs like chair lifting glass
smashing all of these things and and we
you know just going to concede that I
sound old but I'm like when you get
older you go like oh it's up to us it's
all up to us to make the world magic
meaningful and to be like this is why we
don't just jump off a cliff is because
you'll step on a glass and your friends
will lift you up and a guy's going to
sing and hav Nila is a is a it slaps I'm
going to say it slap it's a banger and
I've never admitted this but I've never
been at a Jewish wedding I was just at
one and when they're doing the chair
thing I get so emotional I get so
emotional and a little bit cilantro and
guac jealous like that much jealous that
I'm like we have nothing like that
speaking of meaning do you know the
reason for the glass are you familiar
I've heard different theories in the
same way that the Hindus and the cows
and why they drink milk but don't eat
the meat but I've never heard a good one
give give well I I think this is correct
but I'm now curious to see hear what
other theories you've heard the the
reason for the glass and it is never
more timely than now although it's
always never more timely than now is
that um it represent it symbolizes one
specific thing which is the destruction
of the temple uh in Jerusalem in 70 AD
but but it doesn't really represent that
anymore what it really represents is
that even in times of great uh
celebration Sim as they as they call in
Hebrew one should always remember that
there's tragedy and pain and suffering
and so even in the in the highest moment
of your celebration of a of a life you
smash the glass to remind you that the
world is broken and then it needs they
call what tun it needs repair and you
should always be mindful of that that
means no worries that's right tun oam
what a wonderful thing I only do the
Rogan one it means no worries that's my
Lion King that's my lion king um I only
do the Nathan Lane one the cuz that's my
Lion King that's obviously everyone's
Lion King um yeah it I say completely
humorlessly um that's everyone's Lion
King it is true that that is everyone's
Lion King I love that and that really I
remember it was one of my first maab
thoughts now you're speaking Hebrew
macabra thoughts I do have Hebrew
jealousy when you said that I got chills
I you wish you spoke Hebrew I just well
we're back to meaning making yeah and
culture I I understand uh Hebrew school
and and you know you tell me there there
there might be a certain UND desirable
element to that but I'll say from like a
they do call My People undesirables
yes we'll be right back and we come back
Russ Russ that's what I was G to say so
mosha like the adrenalized sort of way
that you go about the Torah yeah was
that good yeah that was it was just kind
of standard cocky kind of he is standard
cocky let's not talk about Russell Brand
again on the which is Sports
Center
you tuned back into to sports center
today we got the 76ers are down 42
points to 12 against the Golden State
Warriors Co is a Lie the election was
stolen this is your new SPAC stepen
a Russell Brand Sports
generals it's absolutely mental they're
at the 50 yard line This is where they
Berry Jimmy Hofer our special guest
today a man close to my heart is racist
Steven Hawking hello Rel and thank you
for having me you know when I liked
basketball was in the
1940s before other the youo rule came
into the
league we're back
[Music]
baby back and it was more layup and
professionally done three-pointers if
there's a sport that's close to my heart
it is yacht racing and I think you know
why it's not the boats if you know what
I'm
saying and you wanted to move away from
Russell BR but it got us here got us
here you got to break a few eggs you got
you got to smash a a few glasses to get
to racist Steven Hawking but my maab
thought in college was wouldn't it be
funny to win the lottery or some other
like you win the Nobel Peace Prize
whatever it is and instead of an AC
acceptance speech you kill
yourself wait on stage yeah just yeah
what it was was playing with the idea of
really honestly what that tradition is
acknowledging is you go to Disneyland
some of the people in the costumes are
you know going through a breakup right
some of them are having the worst day of
their lives in fact when I drive on the
highway I go just remember some of these
people are having the worst day of their
lives that's that um David Foster
Wallace this is water thing which
changed my life it changed my life too
love this is water unfortunately the
only available recording of it on
YouTube has like weird new age music
over it but I did Force Natasha to
listen to it on like our second date now
that's a good second date that is a good
second date that's a good um third
insufferable second date yeah I would
like to play you a David Foster Wallace
clip with a gift though see there's
different kinds of folks and this is one
of the reasons why we get
along if I heard this is water and I
said to you I just heard this is water
and you're like I heard that like 10
years ago I would be like why didn't you
tell me about it uh I just bigley and I
talk about this all the time we're
advice guys I like I wouldn't say I like
giving it but I I like having received
it and then I like sharing it is a
better way to put it you were recently
on the advice podcast the endless
honeymoon and you were wonderful on that
it's one that I host with my wife
Natasha I'm glad you know what sticks
out for me is when I got a little too
sometimes the kite I let the kite out a
little too much and I started talking
about how your mind we know you can make
sounds in your mind and you can make
images in your mind and when an image
appears in your mind and then it
dissolves it's not dissolving into
nothing it's dissolve I started doing
that and I remember you very skillfully
being like let's go back and like you
moved me on and I was like it was loving
I love going super deep but I loved you
EX expertly hosted me as a guest that's
nice I I you know I I actually love
going off into the ether too no you do
but there is something I'm not going to
say it's too far but sometimes it's like
maybe maybe let's stop well no I would
it actually does connect back to the
book in a weird way which is that I've
been thinking subculture vulture
subculture vulture it's the third panel
that you haven't subculture vulture and
an occasional multure and you have a a
PCT mul it's about my journey through
Garden yeah sub vulture and sometimes a
multas multure comedy and sex and God I
can't think if I named my book
subculture vulture and comedy and sex
and God no no no okay I'd be
thrilled because your book would come up
and it would say uh people also bought
you know what I mean people also bought
the book that he
plagiarized comedy my friend Rob Bell
has a book called uh sex god and mine's
called comedy sex interesting yeah and
that occurred to me and I was like I
think it's fine and did you ever talk to
him about it no that's how fine I
assumed it was but like very very
different oh yeah so what I was going to
say was oh the third panel can I mean
that one actually has the what it is oh
wait I want to guess it I mean death
culture queer culture no uh sobriety
sobriety what is this isn't this just
like a genderless bathroom um that is
not a genderless bathroom that is that
is the AA symbol it is in fact yeah
didn't was so you know the queer thing
that you saw it is pink is uh up an
upside down triangle in a circle oh and
the right side up triangle in the circle
is is the AA symbol and that each side
of the triangle represents like Unity
service and Recovery I guess the three
prongs are you worried that like you
know an upside down cross means
Antichrist don't you think that's a
little homophobic for a symbol that's a
very interesting uh idea and is I was
definitely hoping that nobody would
notice that that was the reason I put it
on the cover slow pushing what's supp
you're going to to say called out you
tuned in right to right welcome back to
Sports Center are you punching down um
but the aa's aa's 12 I'm not in AA
anymore and it's been a long time since
I hav been and it was a very long and
arduous kind of process and that's what
that section of the book is about is my
kind of that would be triple a like a
like a a tonal you know like how a means
not so you're not an A A oh I'm a a AA
which means I can on you to toone me cuz
I know you're not drunk but isn't a
tonal kind of anti- tonal I would say
that I'm not aoral then anti-oral yes or
just no moral no moral yeah but I
couldn't say that either because I still
you know it's been I think probably 10
years since I've been to a meeting um
I've been sober I just was sober I was
going to say that's great that is great
right it's not like saying like I don't
see my therapists anymore like we did it
well that's funny you say that because
it's that's a real taboo really that's
why I was careful inside of a it's not a
taboo for me I'm happy to say it I I
would not ever tell a person in recovery
I grew Beyond recovery I don't think
that I first of all don't think that
that's true but but you would be it is
more of a taboo to say that to be in an
AA meeting and say I'm over this I don't
need it anymore I'm moving on it no
longer has anything to offer me than to
say I am going to take LSD in the
bathroom of this meeting right now that
would be accepted more much more yeah it
would it would create much less
antagonism to say something like that
than to say I'm over this I know
parallel but it reminds me of how like
you can be smoking somewhere and then
people get mad and you're like it's weed
you know like there's a parallel there
where it's like don't worry it's weed
it's not a cigarette I hear what you're
saying I think the parallel is pretty
clear it it would be you tell me as a
Christian parallel it would be it will
be right going into being at a church
and saying I love I love the church I
love Christianity but I'm moving past it
and I don't need it anymore you have
okay so Romos we're not going to this is
tricky I'm not even in AA I I love AA
meaning I love AA too and I think that I
know but I feel like a a a phony saying
that having not I've been to some
meetings and stuff but I wouldn't say
like I'm in the thing I love it meaning
Richard Roar wrote a book that I love I
think it's on the Shelf called breathing
underwater it's called um God in the 12
steps and I just gobbled it up and
compare and despair and worker among
work so all these things have like
informed my not not drinking and stuff
so I'm nervous even though I'm not a
part of it but Romos does have some I
remember listening to it and being like
this ganger I know the passage I can't
even tell you I swear to God Pete this
is not a joke swear to me I swear to
Pete I swear to Comedy and sex and gods
um that the clip of Romos talking about
what you're about to talk about is only
available I'm not kidding on YouTube
with new age music overall I swear that
is true I can tell you where to find it
clean but I know the exact one that
you're talking about it's about people
becoming addicted to to being sober
exactly and and he kind of makes a
cheeky joke where he's like my name is
uh Bill I'm an addict and he goes I'm
I'm dick like his name is Richard so
he's like I'm dick uhhuh meaning and
this is really thin ice so let's just
enjoy the thrill like me being Russell
Brand for Halloween just enjoy how weird
this
is we do whether it's AA or anything
there's always a temptation as human
beings to want an identity and to and to
pour yourself into different containers
and spirituality at its like most
expansive is all about dropping all of
it yeah and going like yeah that's a
game that's part of my story I'm in
recovery but really like he would say
that that's kind of a trap is to be like
I'm this or you could say I'm a vegan
godamn it like anything that makes you
rigid he would be like can we introduce
some some air into this well any to talk
about any I I it is hard to talk about
and it was one of my main anxieties in
writing this particular book um was I
knew that part of this book was going to
be discussing in Frank terms cuz my
first book I I know that it it really
affected a lot of people in their early
recovery Journey my first book is all
about my sort of trials and tribulations
as a young C The Catcher And The Ry it's
all about like me discovering phonies in
the world and the guy that shot John
Lennon is a huge fan of yours and that
was by design that was messaging that I
put in in the similar way that the
homophobic symbol is on the cover of
this that messaging the Fibonacci
sequence if you read every fourth word
seven word whatever the Fibonacci
sequences that says find him yes find
him and I wrote the Fibonacci sequence
uh I am a
Fibonacci I am Fibonacci I am
Progressive Fibonacci only who I hater
is is a racist Steven Hawking we're both
the members of the scientific Society
but he just keeps talking about the race
and the woke culture that he thinks is
infecting our our minds a woke a mind of
virus my God being woke is basically a
license to be like I don't even want to
finish the Riff I'll tell you who I like
watching is that Tucker Carlson only on
X now where comedy is still
legal
thank you Elon but I okay I I don't want
to lose this because it was it is
important for me to say your first book
was very helpful in helpful for people
I've had a lot of people write me on uh
on social media and say like I was I was
a teenager in rehab and somebody gave me
your book and it touched me and and and
it helped me get sober and it helped me
stay sober and that is so incredibly
meaningful to me the fact that anything
I've ever and I'm sure you you you do
this too because you're kind of foray
into discover discussing spirituality
like the idea that my that my comedy
career had a byproduct of being
emotionally or psychologically
meaningful to anybody is like something
I never saw coming and also really
meaningful to me CU I care about people
is the comparison if my second book was
kind of like I'm I'm seeing the validity
of atheism is it kind of like that yes
and I had a real anxiety in writing this
book because it's true it's true it's
truth it's my story is that AA um
defined my young life I got sober and I
was 15 years old old I was by far the
youngest person in any AA meeting that I
went to for the first 5 years of my
recovery in I'd go to Young people's
meetings and they were called young
people's meetings and I would walk in
and I would still be 5 10 years younger
than everybody there I was the mascot
that was that and it was this defining
characteristic of who I was and I took
it on in such a deep way by the time I
was you know four or five years sober I
was it was what you say it was the the
the primary identifier I was so proud of
how long I had been sober and how young
I was and these days when I tell people
how long I've been sober I it has ating
of embarrassment I feel embarrassed to
tell people I know Comics that like when
I was starting I was like I've been
doing it for four years and they're like
I'm at the point where you don't like
telling people how long you've been
doing it it is it's exactly that but it
it it completely I mean I what the about
racial racist
you I just saw a new candidate for
president who's very exciting to me keep
going is it uh the Kennedy one oh RFK I
thought it was going to be it could have
been a fun riff if it was uh what's the
guy's name the Indian guy I don't know
ramas Suare there's a guy named ramare
running right oh I really hope I'm right
anyway keep going not worth it but I was
just looking at you and remembering how
funny you are thank
you but yeah I got I I went into into
the program so young i' been in rehab
since I was 13 my mom was sending me to
rehab from like about a year into my
drug use I started using drugs when I
was like 12 and I've been in and out of
rehab and been forced to go to 12ep
meetings and by the time I like really
needed discovered that I needed help I
was 15 and walked into that Monday night
young people's meeting and said that I
said in front of a group of people help
me I need help I can't keep doing this I
don't know how to stop I mean my whole
thing was that like my primary
identifier as a young person was that my
problem was not my problem my problem
was you my problem was the adults
surrounding me my problem was the o
Police Department Public Schools my
mother my therapist my family therapist
my rehab counselor like and then one day
I had this like sort of realization that
it didn't make sense that every other
person in the world was my problem and
that maybe my problem was me the cliche
yeah everything's a no but and all great
stuff is cliche but like if if you hate
everyone the problem might be you they
say in AA actually if nobody else
measures up it might be time to check
your yard stick right and and I had this
realization like a like a bolt of
lightning like I'm the problem and it's
actually my drinking and drug use that's
the problem by the way that quote I'm
still wow the yard stick a great quote
well AA I'm going around being like you
stink like way more than I want to yeah
yeah totally oh you're not like and the
and the it's like you're not a genius
you know what I mean like keep going oh
well anyway I I realized like all I have
to do with that realization it's so
simple it's such a simple process like
I'm the problem the drinking and the
drugs are the problem all I have to do
is quit the drinking and the drugs
that's it's like so simple and then I
which is kind of adct mind right yeah
and white to think it's to think that
the problem really is that simple well
isn't it kind of like removing a tumor
instead of changing lifestyle at all
well the analogy that I've actually
heard um which I is is actually in the
book and I think is a pretty powerful
one um is that sorry we have to go to
the mid
rolls modern mammo
wait what what are some of his Black
Rifle coffee is the only one that gets
you alert enough
iaon it's been tested it's been tried
um I've the analogy I've heard the
analogy I've heard that's really good is
that it's a lot like having a problem
with your car um you're driving along
you hear a noise and you think that the
problem is is the noise you think that
the problem is the noise but so but you
just sort of ignore the noise and you
hope it'll get better then the noise
becomes a grinding and then the grinding
becomes a clunk and then it breaks yeah
and you think oh my God this is the
problem you take it to the mechanic and
the mechanic the what they do is they
tell you they diagnose the problem and
the problem is is you bu a busted
transmission the problem is is whatever
the problem is but that doesn't get you
any closer to solving the problem all it
does is give you the knowledge and the
information necessary that you would
need in order to solve the problem like
start fixing the problem I I thought you
were going to say this and it's clear
you are saying this I was waiting for
the word symptom it's like drinking
isn't the drinking obviously is the
problem now we're going to talk
abstractly drinking isn't the problem
it's the symptom but the symptom it's
you know is what's interesting about it
is that the symptom becomes so loud and
so pronounced and so diseased and so
destructive and so painful that it is it
it you couldn't even possibly see the
underlying issues until you but once you
clean that up then maybe you can cuz you
know how many sober people do I know
several that like stop drinking but then
start drinking 18 cans of Pepsi a day oh
100% or or cigarettes or like what's the
cliche of and this is no Jud this is
Judgment free it's like let's drink
coffee and we're still going to like
something's wrong we're going to fix it
with some other state which makes total
sense completely agree and honestly a
healthier addiction yes the difference
between being an active drug addict an
alcoholic and being somebody that's
smoking two packs of cigarettes a day is
the difference between a person you can
be around and a person you can't yeah so
so I went into AA with that realization
I mean rather I I had this big
realization of this is it's this is it I
I know the solution the solution is to
stop and the the next day when I went to
my drug dealer's house I went to his
house and I told him I'm done oh yeah I
went I go I'm done buddy thank you
before you said that it was pretty funny
it's like so I left the meeting I met my
drug dealer no no no that is that is
where we're going so I went to his house
I said goodbye buddy I'm out I'm out of
the game this is it I can't do this
anymore I'm done and I left and then
that's like going to the homepage of
like youu jiz or whatever and to tell it
you're out of porn to write to write
customer service I'm out of here and and
you see all the thumbnails that incite
every part of your brain that it is like
that you're going to the candy shop to
be like [__] you Wonka and I don't mean
shalam that ain't my Wonka I prefer
shalam and
Rogan Rogan is in I don't know you did a
Rogan Riff on The Lion King oh Seth
Rogan yeah I went to Joe
I that's what I thought you were saying
too when you first rifted it yeah I
thought Joe Rogan did did The Lion King
Rogan has been dethroned as The Lion
King or as the primary Rogan you're
saying he's not the primary Rogan I
remember uh a very funny comic Mike
Holmes when we started together I was
like who's going to be the holes like
I'm not there this isn't but I think we
both were kind of like you know you want
to be Chappelle or or you want to be
right and it's sucks that you both got
dethroned by su su yeah Su Holmes Su
Holmes
I would say that's the primary you got
me with like a na na na business like
you got me like you got me so hard we
both lost to Su you both lost you never
had a chance we didn't we weren't even
close my drug dealer yep I went and I I
told him I was done and then the next
day when I went to his house to buy a
bag he looked at me and he goes what are
you doing man he goes you said yesterday
you quit here you are again today what
like what's wrong wrong with you you
know you've really got a problem and as
the drug dealer said this when your drug
dealer does he [__] with you no he
was serious wow and when your drug
dealer does an intervention on you this
is the time to seek help and that is
what I did truly funny wait you didn't
buy the bag I bought the bag and then I
went to a meeting the next day you're
going to do the bag got to buy the bag I
relate so hard because of my issues with
food to the like your one of my issues
with food is like if you eat a piece of
cake it's like the is broken which is
the dumbest oh you've already started
eating the cake you might as well finish
the cake but it's that black and white
it's like you're looking at the calendar
and this day is now xed yeah and then
you're like well if it's already xed if
I'm already going to go to the meeting
tomorrow I'm already like oh I realized
it's a new rock bottom it's a new low
point you might as well do the thing and
that is not really I can see it both
ways it's not how reality works the
rabinal teaching if not now when right
right it's now just do it now well one
day at a time exactly one moment at a
time and then I know it's one day at a
time but then there is no but one moment
at a time is is is AA wisdom they say if
you can't make it for one day make it
for one hour if you can't make it for
one hour make it for one second it is
part of the wisdom of AA I love it and
some of the most profound wisdom in AA
to talk out the other side of my face
there is something interesting about
just the way life is set up Sun coming
up sun going down us being up us going
to sleep
and I really some sometimes that can
hurt me meaning well this day is [__]
I ate cake I might as well eat a whole
pizza as well it can also help me I
think this is the phenomenon of New Year
we love like it's New Year's Day why
does that work it's like it does though
there's like a collective feeling in the
air I can just tell more people well
it's exactly what you're saying about
applying meaning where there is none or
maybe there is some and and we've
discovered it I don't know but I will
say that like the rhythm of my life um
has become you know I'm not a
particularly religious Jew but I love
yum Kapur and and I have this strange
connection is that the dish with the
little
Krispies wait I can't even figure out
what yapor is like they put the little
that's yum kapor oh I'm sorry that's
brought to you by yum kapor yum kapor
yeah why doesn't yum kapor exist we
should who's renting this house does
like care packages of wonderful Hala and
matal and all these she yum kapore do a
break the fast on yam kapor boom why do
you love yam kapor well because it is a
an annual assessment of the things that
have gone wrong like the idea I told you
about may his name be blotted out of the
book of life that is the idea that on
that day God is in heaven almost
literally with a quill going Pete will
make it because he has atoned mosha will
not make it because I obviously don't
believe in that but I do believe in this
is helpful as a symbol I don't even know
if if I believe in any any of it but I I
do love the idea of an annual I'm
cleansed I'm done and I and it's weirdly
connected to to Burning Man for me
because of the the way that oh sorry I
spoiled one of the tiles oh would I have
gotten it I think I would have that's
clearly a wooden man so every year on
Labor Day I've been a burning man now
this was my 22nd year in a row I went
for the first time in 1996 I used to
work there for 15 years I worked up
there and well into my comedy career
where my agents and my other comedian
friends were like why the [__] are you
taking a month off a year to go be like
a psychedelic security guard up at
Burning Man like I I was in a sober
burner as a sober person never having
gotten high there but I every year on
Labor Day they set the Man on Fire and
if it has any actual meaning to me it's
for me this is going to sound so corny
but it but it really does have meaning
to me like it is the beginning of my
high holiday period I watch the man get
set on fire what that means to me and it
means whatever it means to however many
people that are looking at it what it
means to me is like life is temporary we
are temporal we are all a man about to
catch fire by the way uh Terence McKenna
summarizes every psychedelic it doesn't
matter how strong it is the message is
the same it goes nothing lasts forever
right that's the whole thing summarized
as well and we are in denial of that
constantly I think it's so funny that
we're ice sculptures basically yeah
we're going around melting I've I've
never talked about this but sometimes
when I'm falling asleep I'm like oh I
could do a short film where everybody
has like a something like a dog collar
like a met almost like saw and there's a
spinning saw blade coming at you and it
moves ever so slowly the reason I don't
do it is it's too dark and it's also too
obvious but if you saw someone going
like buying a Ferrari and they have a
saw blade and they're test driving like
woohoo I'm like that is the cosmic joke
it's like and Al so Ferrari can be fun I
see it both ways my friend Jacob
describes life as just being yub y yakub
uh as life as being on um an airport
sidewalk moving sidewalk and then and
the and the end of it is just the abyss
and we we have that much time yeah and
so when I see the man at burning man
gets set on fire to me that's what it
symbolizes what Terence McKenna said
what you said the saw blade is in front
of you we are all a man about to catch
fire and so what matters is like what
are we doing in the meantime so the
process of like looking at my year P how
I want to live better how I want
to and you need a big ass
ritualistic C group celebration prompt
right and we we're running out of
prompts I completely get it and and
America said when we got here get rid of
your prompts leave them at Ellis Island
we're not doing prompts anymore yeah we
don't do prompts and that is I in some
ways like another theme of this book
which is the the the lack stop
mentioning I can't the lack of ritual I
can the lack of ritual in this I'm 100%
JK subculture vulture available now yes
available now for your reading pleasure
depending on when this book comes out
available right now this episode what
did I say book yeah I can't stop
mentioning the
book but but it's about what sub what
subculture what subculture represents
for us yeah is in a world where you know
you don't go to the town parade where
they have the weird costumes that have
been around since the r an Empire and
kill the bull and go to the and go to
the bull fighting match and we don't
have that and so what we do what we did
in our era was we would find the
universes that seduced us right for you
it was the church for a while then it
was comedy for a while and then it was
psych now it's psychedelics and you've
moved past that it's like it's this sort
of chance pinball slap of like what is
life and you look back only in in
hindsight in rearview uh Vision do you
see oh I see the pattern like oh I was
supposed to start um in Bible camp but
then I was supposed to have my marriage
dissolved which was going to ping me
into comedy which was going to ping me
into success which was going to push me
into this psychedelic World which is
going to make me meet Val which is going
to put you know it's like this whole you
can't see it when you're moving but you
can see it when you look back and yeah
and part of I think the lament uh my
lament is that and and I know and I I
know how my lament so your book is
another title would be my lament my
struggle
so just this the real subtitle is my
struggle subculture vulture mov um in
when it gets translated it's going to be
such a success it's going to get
translated into Germany in America
people think you wrote Catcher in The
Ry in Germany they're pretty sure that
guy wrote M let me did you know that the
the American OA JD Salinger same guy and
of Hitler same
guy who are the phonies
aice the
phonies oh my God the
phonies we are we are not the phonies we
are the people the vul um but my my my
lament you're so funny Pete it's hard to
um stay in the inere no stay in it stay
in it but my lament that I really is
that and I again I'm self-conscious
about this being like a old man shakes
his fist at Clouds type of memoir but
there is something about the pre-
internet era that we were raised in
which was that your path your your
hindsight path it happened to you and it
was chance it was like the reason that I
fell into drug addiction is because I
had this incredibly painful childhood um
and not a lot of people have incredibly
painful childhoods but then I found the
kids at the back of the portable at the
in public schools and they happen to say
come here you know and I happen to go
shoplift a pack of camel wides um and my
friend happened to to he wasn't my
friend at the time happened to see me
smoking one and he happened to say you
seem cool so come this way come smoke
cigarettes with us at the back of the
school and we happened to get high and
it happened to S to be the the the balm
that I needed to finally feel okay right
and that happened to be such a a an
intoxicating bomb uh literally
intoxicating but also a figuratively
that I lost control of it and I happen
to have this realization that happened
to put me into an AA meeting and where I
raised my hand and asked for help and I
happened to go to I happen to get bored
enough in sobriety that it led me to the
Rave scene which happened to lead me to
Burning Man which happened to you know
lead me to like who I am as a person and
I happen to be born into this hidic
world this Jewish world that was only a
part of my life 6 weeks a year and I
happened to go to Israel on a semester
abroad one year and that semester
happened to get cut short uh because of
the situation there which is more tragic
than ever and I happen to go to New York
City on on because I didn't have
anywhere to go that semester and I
happen to run into Chelsea who I
happened to go to Oakland Public Schools
with and she happened to say I'm doing
standup now and I happen to follow her
to an open mic rather than going to a
rave that night I happen to go wow I
could try that too and I happen to do an
open mic and it became my life and then
I happened to meet my my Natasha and we
happen to fall in love with each other
and have a child and give me this life
you're looking at the manifestation your
daughter do you say your daughter's name
publicly we don't but you know oh that's
right that I'm remembering that you
don't yeah your daughter's life is like
the material representation when you're
saying that I've been thinking about
this a lot lately it's like Plinko
exactly Plinko Plinko or pinball is the
reference that that I always think of
and it feel and and I always say
speaking of atheism if you are a
believer in God or Spirit or destiny
it's [__] it's breathtaking and if you
are a a materialist and you're you truly
are an atheist and you believe in in
nothing and Randomness it's equally well
it's equally breathtaking ter oh if
Randomness created your child if
Randomness created your life this
beautiful life that you've got Pete this
beautiful life that's right in my alley
you're meaning you're kind of you can
call it God or you can call it
Randomness and I'm like at this at the
end of the day your experience of a
maybe not a reverence but an observation
of you could call it chaos
absolute nothingness absolutely
meaninglessness and look at what it's
doing it's so strange and so wild and so
miraculous or whatever the word would be
yeah and I guess the asterisk always is
well I look back on my Plinko and my
life is tragic you know I mean I'm not
trying to say that always Destiny gives
you this beautiful end result I'm just
but but all the pain that I walked
through all the pain that I experienced
it all is Grace Grist for the mill Grist
for the mill as my as my boy well he
also say suffering is Grace too my my
example is very similar to yours but
it's you know it's a divorce and it's
like I I didn't want this uh I think
it's on the wall I think it's Paul RC
but it's it's first comes the fall then
comes the recovery from the fall both
are the grace of God yeah which I know
is religious sounding and because it is
but but it's that kind of hindsight but
it's not even just because it turned out
materially successful and now you have a
book and now you have whatever
it's just what's happening it's it's
just all what's happening well it is it
is and and in hindsight you can only see
that it happened and and you can only
see it the pattern and you can choose to
make meaning it's just what we were
talking about at the beginning you make
meaning where there is none or maybe
where there is something that you
discover but there's no way to see the
meaning until you've done the thing I
mean it's like that Chinese proverb you
know that Chinese proverb about maybe
yeah I love I tell maybe all the time
yeah I'm sure you've I it would be it
wouldn't be much of a you made it weird
if you never mayed yeah you got to maybe
I mayed recently because um I forget
what it was well without retelling the
proverb it's you can look it up the
maybe or the perhaps proverb there was a
man of questionable descent in a country
filled with communist Stephen yes uh it
doesn't say of questionable descent it's
just a man listen I'm just doing my own
interpretations I'm one of the great
minds of the 20th century you think I
don't understand a [__]
proverb
you you don't think it chaps my head
that this proverb with great wisdom
comes from that same place where they're
bootlegging DVDs of my own book what the
[__]
bro racist Stephen it's so glad I'm so
glad to have you on the show glad to
glad to bee with I disagree with you
glad to be back
brother the incriminating brother
no no no we're not brother no no no no
no no no no no no no no no I've been
tripping out lately I've been thinking
about Plinko a lot lately because you
know this is just going to sound however
it's going to sound it's okay but I am
changing your life right now I'm
changing Katie's life you're changing my
life and I know that sounds like oh lava
lamp smoke a joint but
like obviously it's the most obvious
thing in the world that you came here so
geographically you've been changed but
the ideas that we share will inform your
behavior the way that you drive on the
highway is changing the entire world
yeah if you look at the ripples either
you're being kind or you're being unkind
the ripples of that we all have been cut
off and you think about that guy and
then maybe you're a little short with
your partner or maybe you're frustrated
and then you drink and then you or like
you could even look at it more
superficially and be like because you
came here let's say we canceled the
podcast and you fall off a cliff and
he's like oh he would have been you know
what I'm saying that's the extreme but
it's not paranoia you could also say
because you did the podcast you didn't
fall off the cliff like it's both yeah
but it thought experiments like that or
or or looking at it that way really
brings up the urgency of every ordinary
activity that a smile to a stranger
could stop an Untold horror or or or
could create one you have to you have to
at it both ways you could be like and
now they think I'm a phony and that
makes them angry you so you can't
control it that's paranoia paranoia is
well I am changing the world with
everything I'm doing and saying so I'm
going to stay in my house well you
staying in your house is also the choice
right now you're not at the ice cream
shop and you don't smile at the pregnant
woman who could have saved her life and
she didn't go off the cliff but it's
paranoia Until you realize it's
so like reality is
so yeah that all your only choice is to
surrender and keep walking and keep
going on the on the thing because you're
on the conveyor about whether you're
moving or not cuz it's moving underneath
you well the guy in the house with
the is still there but then when we talk
about God looking out for us I don't
that's not my belief I don't like I've
had wonderful fortune and I can enjoy
the sort of non-literal meaning I don't
think it's the absolute truth of the
absolute mystery I practice attitude I
get emotional thinking about what if I
didn't meet Val sliding door style and
I'm not even saying stop doing that
thank you for this parking spot or
whatever it is I'm not saying that's
stupid or a waste of time but I'm saying
like all of it when we're talking about
Gris for the mill the bad the good right
now we are in eternity we've applied the
illusion of time to it the the concept
it's a useful concept but it's not we're
in this and we're always and forever in
this moment so the only game that I see
that's consistent is how much you
remember yourself and it doesn't matter
if you have Ferraris or a mansion or
even the wife and the child it's
like and that's a real [__] it's like
who's luckier who's better off the guy
job who finds God through all the
suffering or the guy what what breaks my
heart more is when I go to some
multibillionaire
house and I see nothing getting through
and I'm like it's just the ice cream
enema every day and it's just a
different way to jizz every day yeah and
I'm like where is that where is that
right now even when you're talking I
only because I feel like you you'll
enjoy this and I'm going to give it to
you it's like you don't have a life
mosha when you say my life I don't even
even know what you're talking about sad
Guru was talking about this some people
say my life they mean their children
some people mean their money some people
mean their career some people mean their
bodies whatever it is but it's just a
concept but you are life well you know
because it's right now yeah I but drop
the life on that on that tip one of the
most profound things I realized or I
heard in the pandemic and uh you know
that I don't believe much in that
[__] but during the planic it's what
you're talking yeah this Rabbi um was I
saw some video just came into my
algorithm and it really affected me uh
it's it's what you're saying yeah he's
like
we here's the the positive of what just
T is what is happening we all think of
ourselves and our lives as the work we
do the people we see the activities we
engage in what we achieve yeah and then
something like this comes and it all
shuts down and there's nothing and yet
we're still alive we're still us we
still are in the world we still have
life wasn't essential to you and it was
taken away your life was I go and you're
still there that's why Garden of Eden
they're naked they're not naked they
don't have ding-dongs and and boobies
it's a it's talking about you you've yet
to apply the story the story of your
clothes and your job and your thing and
the pandemic did take that away and
there were a lot of us tragedy noted I'm
not trying to be funny all the loss but
there were Quiet Moments washing a dish
going like I am as much I am as I was
when I was doing all some hot meeting
and some big acting job I still am here
I still am Rupert Spyro would say all of
our striving and as a special guide
trying to be special yeah he would say
you're trying to impose the qualities of
your essence which is eternal expansive
perfect infinite gorgeous light you're
trying to push that into your story and
it makes perfect sense he's not saying
stop it but we're trying to aize
ourselves right to the qualities that
our Consciousness has and yeah and like
I I'm I'm when I was listening to you
talk I had this feeling of like what the
[__] are you saying I don't know are you
talking no it is and I don't even know
if what I'm about to say I believe but
it's like what I don't want to be what
what what I consider to be a tragedy and
I'm I'm I'm I'm thinking of this in real
time so I I hope I hope it makes sense
it's like what you're talking about I
don't want to be a victim of just being
pushed down the conveyor belt without
even noticing the process the whole time
many people and me definitely at points
in my life certainly when I was young
and trying to get sober um are unaware
that they're even on the conveyor belt
they're just letting trauma and pain and
misery push them down the line and just
like you said unconscious unconscious I
want to be able to at some point on the
Journey uh look down at the at the at
the flame-throwing chair that's pushing
me towards the abyss and go oh my God
I'm on a ride and and have some agency I
want to at certain points of Life some
Liberation I want to be a pilot not a
passenger
yeah pardon the interruption weirdos
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at next Evo Naturals you guys
know the new year is the perfect time to
move on from things that just aren't
working in your life and with next Evo
natural CBD product oilbased CBD can be
one of those things that isn't working
for you oilbased CBD doesn't mix well
with our waterbased body so you absorb
as little as 6% 6% of the CBD that is on
the label but next Evo Naturals you know
I love CBD but this is a company that
really elevated it because they
developed a clinically tested water
soluble form of CBD water soluble which
means their gummies and capsules are
proven to work faster and absorb four
times better than oilbased products so
you need to go to next o.com and use
promo code weird for 25% off any order
or up to 60% off as a new subscriber I
love their stress gummies it's mixing
adaptogens and CBD and CBD that you can
feel and feel quickly so you can get
that dose just right the ashwana in
there lowers your stress the CBD rounds
it out and gives you a wonderful feeling
of uh well-being try their strongest
gummy ever is new the new Extra Strength
daily Wellness CBD gummies which the
customers love or for for the all-time
best sellers try my beloved stress or
their sleep sleep CBD complex products
find new ways to use CBD with a variety
of convenient options including gummies
capsules and dissolvable powders which
I've been known to put in my smoothies
because I love it like I said it gets
into you four times better and you start
feeling that absorption in about 10
minutes so leave oil behind and start
the year off with more effective and
fast acting CBD from next Evo Naturals
get 25% off any order or up to 60% off
as a new subscriber by using Code weird
at
next next evo.com that's 25% off your
order or up to 60% off a new
subscription at neext evo.com with promo
code weird we're also brought To Us by
our friends at ritual the multivitamin
and the probiotic that I take every
single day if supporting foundational
Health was a sport you would want ritual
on your team they made essential for men
a multivitamin that's based solely on
science and designed to help fill common
nutrient gaps in the diet with 10 key
nutrients I can speak anecdotally for me
I would get my blood work done at my
physical every year I had gaps I took
ritual it filled those gaps according to
the CDC fewer men than women meet the
minimum daily intake recommendations for
fruits and vegetables and men are more
likely to overvalue exercise and
undervalue nutrition will stop it enter
ritual ual a multivitamin specifically
scientifically developed to help men
fill those nutrient gaps in their diet
10 key nutrients in two delayed relap
sorry delayed release capsules which is
key because I take it when I'm fasting
and it doesn't upset my stomach it even
has a minty Essence in every bottle that
makes taking your multis actually
enjoyable it's R rigorously tested and
validated non-GMO vegan gluten and major
allergen free certified EC Corp and made
traceable so you know where these
nutrients are coming from they are the
industry leading sustainability
standards they're meeting the
industry-leading sustainable standards
It's a Wonderful company and it's
something that has absolutely helped my
life essential for men is a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust get 40% off your first
month for limited time at ritual.com
weird this offer is only available
through January 31st start ritual or add
essential for men to your sub
description today that's ritual.com Weir
for 40% off all right everybody back to
mosha it's interesting even the the idea
of being pushed down a conveyor belt is
a story told in time of course right and
that see we haven't talked about this
but uh you and I I mean but like I had
this very profound experience where I
was we were actually at a rert um spy
event and we were eating lunch and I ate
something and I just lodged here and I
thought I was going to choke and I was
in that moment graced something I didn't
want with the sort of inconvenient
Revelation that it's all just now and
when you're dying when you think you're
dying that's all that's happening
meaning we think of our deaths as like
third person like on TV like in a movie
but when it's happening it's just
happening so there was like a it's
already over nness to it in the choking
moment you felt Grace after I was so
scared and I was just sort of like and I
was like oh we have to
go either thoughts like this are
comforting or they're not but it's like
your birth and your death happen in the
same Eternal now and they're happening
kind of simultaneously and we're given
this
provisional thing but here we are like
we can experience and talk about this
right now where is when we met where is
when they wrote Moshi kosi was your name
at the festival it's all gone it's just
this and the just thisness can be very
frightening to a species that's
fascinated with taking pictures and
proving the past remembering the past in
fact your trauma can even be a crutch to
be like I'm real I'm real I'm real and
ramdas would say that too he's like I've
been milking my my bad childhood for 40
years because the true Nightmare and I'm
going to put this to you too when you
have so apart from meditation psyched
contemplation whatever it might be
spiritual things breath work they can
put you into
that now where you're like holy [__]
it's only ever been here and now I've
never been Anywhere But Here and Now it
doesn't matter if I go to Spain I'm here
I go to outer space I'm here it's only
one place it's only one time and and you
feel the piece of
that um I lost my train of thought I
started thinking about Mars you already
you went to well it's funny you say Mars
because all this stuff that you're
talking about with with time what sex
will you remember what you're about to
say maybe well you're the guest I'll
remember what I'm going to say well I is
that this concept the time began when
existence began this is not a new age
concept this is a scientific materialist
concept that at the Big Bang or whatever
it was that started at the beginning of
the of the universe there the question
what happened before the Big Bang is a
is according to theoretical physics and
not according to me I'm not an expert on
theoretical physics but I interviewed on
an old podcast that you did a few times
H Tall Sean Carroll uh who is like a
really un you should definitely have him
on your show really he's amazing but but
he he he explained and and that time and
space is the same thing you know we say
time space it's the same like if you
point up or out or whatever space time
they are not different things the rate
of expansion of the universe and the
concept of time it's the it is literally
in in in physics the same concept so
existence and time it it is I I think
you're right an illusion but it it is
also a concept yeah it's a conceptus
have relative reality right they're real
but they're not what they seem to be yes
exactly right so that even that even
Mars actually does make sense because
Mars is a part of the thing and like
well you're saying what what's the
different like I have a hard time not
believing in time I'm not really it's
just too it's too out there for me to to
go
like you know oh yeah the moment that I
was born in the moment that I died those
are the same moment really but you can
do a thing even for a person that's like
has a hard time with new Agy kind of
ideas like that you can do a thing where
you you know you raise up on the
timeline and you look you know the the
difference between 80 years 120 years
how long I'm going to live if you go up
far enough you go up to Mars and Beyond
and look back down at the timeline and
you go that's essentially the same
moment like it's all kind of there is no
real space between my my like and I'm
talking materially there's almost no
difference between a second and 80 years
and 120 years on the timeline of a
universe well okay so I I'm not I feel
like you trying to summarize Sean
Carroll so I'll try to summarize Rupert
spyra so he says it's very interesting
that we think Consciousness is a
phenomenon that developed in a material
body in order to experience something
that was already happening which was
time and space but he's like it the
whole spiritual thing is kind of
flipping that same Consciousness is and
it creates things like the illusion of
space which is also an illusion meaning
it's not what it seems to be it does I I
understand that you're over here and I'm
over here and and time but but it it's
just a it's a reversal saying instead of
thinking of Consciousness is something
that appeared in something that was
already happening it's like no
consciousness was always just putting
stuff into
itself and then sort
of again this can seem so obvious to me
at times I'm like look at where we are
in outer space endless expansion
infinity and that's us yeah so it would
make something that could hold it hold
it you know and reflect it I feel like
this is why it's so peaceful to look at
the ocean you're like that's me the
waves of my feelings and the the
eternalness and this isn't as esoteric
as it sounds you close your eyes and
you're like where's the boundary right
where does it end but and by the way
it's not even it it it isn't esoteric
literally at all when you think of the
fact the least hidden thing in the world
but it's also literally true it's when
you look at the ocean and you say that's
me it is you yeah I mean it is in this
weird way and we're back to materialism
you know earth when it was first created
if you believe this stuff if you don't
believe that it was created in seven
days but even if you do believe it was
created in seven days Earth was a
lifeless rock it was toou Vu it was cha
it was darkness and void and then it
became ex nio I don't know what Latin
Latin I only know to I'm a tohuu boy I'm
I'm a yum Kipper guy and then sheina
began sheina sheina shakina shikina yeah
shikina Pizzeria
shikina you want some yum kapore come
over to P CH so so the ocean is you I
mean it is you you're literally made of
the ocean and the ocean is made of you
well this is Al okay so that's material
and
also I hear what you're saying you're
coming at it from a scientific I'm
saying it can be both no it is both I'm
completely in agreement with you rert
would say the only thing to seeing I
keep thinking you're gonna say Murdoch
every time you say the word Rupert I'm
like you like you're an acolyte of rert
Murdoch would I don't even know you know
who it is an ACO rer Murdoch I don't
know who that is ruer Murdoch he's the
the owner of Fox News oh so probably sex
Island he must have got he must that has
been largely
misunderstood
just because you're on a private jet
doesn't mean you're partaking of the
Delicacies of an island sometimes you
just want to go to an island and like
sight SE like mosha going to burning man
does not mean he's doing ketamine some
of us just like the smell of sex yeah I
just like the cool cool you think you're
the only one that likes to look at the
ocean and think that's me I do that too
while Bill Clinton is having a managan
eight with 14-year-old I'm just chilling
out shooting some
hoops I'm just seeing the ball rolling
down that is not okay where is Stephen
he's on the basketball court again the
guy loves
Hoops okay the only thing so Rupert's
model which I subscribe to or whatever I
enjoy let's say ruberts model was of age
on the island say what Rupert's model
was of age on the island rubert Murdoch
rubert Murdoch's model she was totally
she was 18 thank you non R this is now
just Mo yeah I've done a lot of research
into the Epstein list and rert was
actually cool oh my God the Epstein list
I don't even like hearing that how did
we go from time and space is the same
thing as infinite reality and the
illusion of life is only as you perceive
it to the Epstein list oh God okay so so
the ocean what is it we think one way is
saying is the ocean exists and
Consciousness is perceiving something
that exists it exists the other model is
saying only Consciousness exists and
when we look at that we go what is the
ocean what is the experience of ocean
well it's seeing and the only thing to
seeing this is Rupert spirro is knowing
it's it's the part of you that knows I'm
seeing the ocean it's knowing smelling
the salt smell is is knowing touching
the water touching is knowing so it all
happens inside of you so that that's
kind of like a fun thing the other thing
is and I've done this in million so I'll
do it real quick but like distance
people are time is is sometimes an easy
one but distance being an illusion
meaning I think this is the coolest
thing in the world the feeling of this
couch which is out
there is experienced in the same place
that I hear my thoughts it's the same
spacious field and that's what we're
talking about awareness awareness is
like an empty room and right now there's
all these little
dots popping up that I call a feeling
but it happens in the same place that
the sound of a distant seagull also
happens not just close to me inside of
me isn't that wild I kind of don't
understand well the I'm adding the story
that that seagull is over there because
that's a very useful model yeah I need
that if I'm hunting seagull I'm not
saying drop it I'm saying but the
experience of something far away that
tree or you or or me or or a feeling or
a thought all
happen saying close to me is not even
close it is me you know it's funny it
come it keep and I hold on I'm going to
snort some KY
yeah now I get it it keeps coming back
to this like uh linkage between LinkedIn
my LinkedIn which if you go to my
LinkedIn I've been working as a a guy at
Best Buy for better part since 2008
since 2008 and The Geek Squad honestly
was your idea that was M that was me I
wrote the Fibonacci sequence M com a
catch on the right and I created The
Geek Squad there's no idea more than
Geek Squad that I'm going to say
millions of people were like I had that
idea like a group of nerds that come and
help you help your mom with her VCR it
was right there um what was I saying uh
I have the other thing I was going to
say but time and space time and space
the ocean you're saying distance time
and space
at the beginning of the universe if you
are a materialist or even if you're not
is that the Universe was a single point
it was a smaller than the smallest small
I mean it was the densest thing it was
the def if you held it in your hand you
would have just sunk to whatever the
bottom of nothing forever right but it
was we were touching you were touching
the ocean and and Mars the non-u
understanding of everything being one
thing is sort of is not even sort of is
backed by the idea materially it's also
materially true within the single point
of the Big Bang contained all of the
contain your heartbreak your body when
you were in junior high wishing you went
to the dance and everyone at that dance
and my daughter and your daugh and
Natasha and comedy and the the trip to
New York and New York and Chelsea and
open mics and blah blah blah all the way
back until the first absolute pinpoint
of reality right and so we get to time
that was the first concept that was
introduced to me in AA yes was that idea
that idea of one day at a time that was
that incredibly laughably
simplistic axom one day at a time which
almost feels insulting but it's not one
day at a time is stop looking at
something that doesn't exist called
mosha or moshe's life and just be in the
moment 100% because when you
drop I I was my friend Noah hafeld wrote
this great piece about being with ramas
and and he was talking about his trauma
and they they did these exercises that
really for lack of a better just to say
it quickly brought them just into the
naked yeah now and and then Romas not to
be cute or dismissive he was like
where's your trauma he was like just we
drag so many things with us like Santa's
sack of toys the giantest sack and we're
dragging it around and this is
psychedelics and otherwise you just go
like what are we doing you know what is
a good otherwise is people who are dying
they're like why am I not talking to my
whatever and I understand there's times
to cut people out of your life I'm not
saying that say in that Clarity of like
the naked potential of
infinite moment this moment you you kind
of go like I actually did ketamine and
that was a big thing I was like the past
doesn't exist it's funny you say that
what are we doing we're dragging it I go
to meet you for lunch and I you're my
beloved friend I'm still I have to do
work to go it's interourse in Miracles
it's like no one sees anything all they
see is the past all they see is the past
and it robs the moment of its infinite
potential to surprise you yeah well I
describe it as this um trauma as this
when you have a trauma occur and this is
also Plinko this is the bad plink this
is dark Plinko the price is wrong
[__]
uh it is yes the price is wrong [__]
what happens to all of us I have started
to think this I know this in AA and I
have started to think this about
everyone I know it's true with addicts I
know that it's but I kind of think it's
true with everybody is you have a trauma
that occurs I mean even you Pete who've
done extensive work on self-improvement
even you even me even Romos yeah have a
trauma and what you do is you you your
little you know elves inside of your
Soul walk over and they with some mortar
and some bricks and they they they wall
off the trauma and you say we're not we
won't go there anymore okay we're going
to go around there which is fine if you
have a few traumas but if you have too
many traumas uh too many things you
start to build these walls where you're
what was what was a what was a path was
is now a labyrinth and what was a a walk
is now a a Plinko youed to be a rotary
you just go around it but now you get
lost in it exactly and all of you're in
the own and you're being fueled this
trauma you don't even this what I was
say I I was saying about I lost a friend
this week to addiction and it's
it's re really this week has been really
hard in that particular way and I've
been thinking about this a lot like when
you meet an addict or an alcoholic you
look from the outside uh and you go and
and I think this isn't just true with
addiction this is true with like sort of
everybody that you know that is fueled
by their own trauma um you look at them
and you go why don't it's so [__]
obvious what you need to do like it's so
simple do stop doing this Behavior stop
feeling sorry for yourself do this do
that get a job whatever it is and it's
so obvious and you're not wrong you're
actually correct it is obvious and it is
clear to you because you're standing
from the outside looking down at the
Labyrinth and going just [__] take a
right and then you're at the center of
the yeah you're on the bird's eye view
and from for them it's impossible they
can't even see the maze cuz they're
stuck in between the hedges that they've
built that was on the crown remember I
haven't seen all of it and it's not a
spoiler but D and her boyfriend what's
his name uh the I'm not gonna Dodie
Dodie doie Dodie so D and Dodie are in
the hotel room uh and they're saying
like your own problems are so obvious to
other people right and Val and I talk
about the this all the time cuz she'll
say like with my with my folks why are
you doing the same thing and expecting a
different result and at least I in that
regard I would call myself consciously
unconscious meaning I'm still
unconscious but at least I'm going I'm
on this treadmill like I like yeah but
the real goal is to be consciously
conscious but but that and so when you
have that Labyrinth that you've built AA
psychedelics spiritual work is that
where you're gonna say ketamine did that
make you think of something um well I
was going to say that it is interesting
that there are a lot of studies that
have been done about people that are
dying yeah they are literally physically
dying and they're given uh psilocybin
mushroom um Doses and they have this
realization on the other end of unease
and a comfort I mean I'm sure there're
still an ease some ease yeah but it
sounded like you said unease uh no no an
ease yes correct they they come out the
other end with more comfort about their
death this goes back to my point is the
only game in town is is is not even an
understanding it's not like an
intellectual like I understand
philosophically what's going on it's a
recognition of what's happening right
the Eternal nature of yourself of
reality the elusory nature the passing
nature that's why I'm saying all
psychedelics are just Whispering don't
don't look for it here don't look for it
here don't try to even win it don't get
me wrong I'm loving this conversation
I'll
beade Frid night two of the my and
afterwards my was tingling and Matt my
my wonderful opener he was buzzing and I
look I like
enjoyment and I
go start the stopwatch like when it
doesn't even make it back to the hotel
with you right it did it lasted till the
next day I was still in a great mood but
like Saturday early you bombed pretty
hard I heard Matt called me and told me
it's funny Saturday early was more what
I would call normal shows it was
actually Sunday early cuz it was
Saturday Sunday weekend and then you go
like it's not in objective reality what
you're looking for isn't there so these
people take mushrooms I can't presume I
can just say what's happened to me on
mushrooms and mushrooms say this is all
ending but let me show you what doesn't
end let me show you and guess what good
news bad news this is all sort of
nonsense this is written on running
water yeah or it's Steam whatever you
want to say but good news that's not who
you really are that's the whole message
right right right and I I think that
there's a corollary in this in that kind
of trauma work too it's like those those
walls that you built they aren't
actually you they're not even your I
mean I guess they're a part of you but
they're not your trauma even they're
they're not essential to you right to
say your point like your Rabbi not your
Rabbi but the rabbis point about the
pandemic spirituality is about what
can't be taken away yeah and what you
could even just look at that
scientifically and say that would be the
most interesting thing or the most
important thing I can take away your
identity I can take away your career all
the things I don't even want to say them
because it's so it's like but it could
and you'd still be there so what is that
it reminds me your memory could go away
and you'd still be there actually it's
funny you say about memory I I was at
New Year's there was like a world
renowned happiness expert at the party I
was at she's like a professor of
happiness she's a psychology Professor
that's got to be a rough gig well cuz
you're in your you're just having a bad
mood like you have a [__] that you can't
quite get out and and you had the wrong
meal on the airplane you just can't be
in a bad mood and now you have to go up
and be like no I'm not even no I'm not
even kidding we did a toast at the
beginning of the meal and we're like to
2024 being a better year for all of us
and she I'm not even kidding she goes
yeah but we're probably going to be run
by a dictatorship next year I like you
you doing
that how how how sway I mean I it was
like well you can't do that you're the
you're the you're the happiness but
anyway what she said to me is that I
said what's the most happy what do you
think the most happy animal in is I say
a dog because dolphin okay I'm I'm G say
no on Dolphin I've never seen a dog
prancing in the waves with 12 friends
well yes those are nice moments but but
the problem The
Cove oh but but uh dolphins have to find
fish they got to find that Herring dog
they have a group in the secret language
no they definitely seem and they team up
with other mamals within the group I
would say of all animals I'm going to go
with you now because I see what you're
saying dogs have a great system I
sometimes look at this dog my own dog
and I'm like who were you before that
you get to be not just a dog but like a
well-off dog I mean imagine yes yes like
who's the person you worship the like
Romos or or or rert right I'm not saying
you worship him or Val or what whoever
you love just the most yeah and you just
like wow this is like the king imagine
you're just every day rer Romos comes
over he G kisses you on the forehead he
gives you a be delicious meal he plays
with you for a while he's like I love
you man I love you and Cuddles with you
and then he's like I'm actually feeding
you as well all your material needs are
met by me get up on my couch come on up
on R's couch come on we're gonna play
and and you don't and and by the way and
I have an understanding that he's
special oh yeah and also you don't ever
think you you're not smart enough to
think Romos really like me I'm going to
die someday aren't I you're just in that
Eternal Bliss of just like getting well
this is eart he says the animal kingdom
is a great key to us CU have you ever
watched an animal die like I watched my
cat dying and they're not panicking in
the way that that we do right they're
like yeah leaves fall from trees they
decompose and they become trees like
this why wouldn't this happen but
they're not even thinking they're not
thinking any of that of course but
they're just like oh my heart's stopping
but the pro it seems like things are
slowing down a bit but they don't go y y
yum y y y yum yum they're not doing that
but the problem with the animal kingdom
is 90% of their life in the wild is just
like this acquisition of food yeah so
thats the dog yeah the dog so I'm
thinking dog but anyway you're thinking
dolphin I like that cuz dolphin Surf and
that is my happy place yeah but I I said
that to her what's the most happy uh
animal and she thought about for a while
she goes demented people people with
dementia yeah she said they're pretty
happy not when they realize they have
dementia but when they get into the Zone
where they no longer remember they had
dementia those people report a very very
H well memory is creating all the all
the sad sure yeah this a sad Guru thing
it's like our faculties that make us
incredible memory and imag ination yeah
that is what separates us as a species
it's it's all this human potential is
linked to memory and Imagination and
memory and Imagination are also it's a
double-edged sword that's really
interesting have you read sapiens I have
it in every form you can possibly have I
haven't read it yet I haven't read it's
great I love it uh and what he says is
what makes us us and I don't think it
contradicts what you're saying I just
maybe it adds a new widget or maybe
they're contained within memory and
Imagination is that what makes a human
being the most exceptionally successful
organism of all time um is our ability
to tell stories to create Mutual myths
uh and in the animal kingdom you are
incapable of spreading your uh pod past
your tribe right because at at a certain
point you come to a group of dolphins or
chimpanzees and you're like who the [__]
are you this is our territory [__] you
we say I'm an American and then oh I
meet An American in New York and then we
go oh we're both Americans I'm a Jew oh
we're both Jews I I'm a comedian we
create these mythologies and then and we
live inside of them and it allows us to
create webs of connection that then
allow us to cooperate and make Farms
like mushrooms and the interconnectivity
of the forest we're doing it with ideas
exactly and it allows us to cooperate
for better for worse you kind of you
just made me realize I I haven't been to
a McDonald's in 20 more years but when I
see the golden arches it kind of makes
me smile oh advertisement is is
capitalizing on that on that very myth
yes I mean exactly are you and when they
talk about it the colors of McDonald's
and the and the values of McDonald's it
is like another ideology oh it is there
have you um there is uh have you watched
Adam Curtis documentaries they're
they're they're fantastic and uh
hypernormalisation is is one and uh and
uh oh gosh I'm going to forget now that
I'm trying to reference it the one that
is about um that is about advertisement
uh but it
is Adam Curtis but in it he describes
how adverti modern advertisement began
to understand the concept of the
subconscious in order to get people to
cooperate with the desire of the market
and one thing in particular that one of
the case studies he sites is that women
used to not smoke women weren't smokers
because Slims well cigarettes cigarettes
were for men right they looked like
cowboys and they're little dicks I me
wasck sure got your little dick fire
Death testosterone and somebody looked
and said wait half of people are women
we're missing out on all this so all
they started to do was think how could
women smoke and then began things like
Virginia Slims come a long way baby come
Modern Woman you have aob well when they
do that when advertisers to do that it's
like what does your adver what is your
customer look like and that's the first
step is they're like well she's
independent right she's successful she's
driven she has at all and she can and
she's thin by the way right Virginia
it's as aspirational it's like not going
to give the women the camel wides as you
said earlier is for men the wide ass
dick I want to be yeah big dick big big
bulging muscles virus limb so they
basically paratroop into your shared
mythology you know this is an interloper
that you don't even know has arrived oh
I Am Woman Woman means something boom
all of a sudden you've got this mole
that says you know what women do women
smoke Virginia Slims and it's like super
powerful psychological magic yes that
we're all sort of being manipulated by
now and more so now than ever in our
algorithms and this is like I said this
is my lament is that this is my struggle
is that life used to feel more magically
accidental and it used to feel more like
Plinko and now it feels more like you're
on a water slide or you be there's a
feeding tube yes when when we talk about
the Plinko of me okay I'm going to sound
like an old man shaking his fist at the
crowd so Richard roar's definition of
evil is anything that lies about the
fundamental nature of reality okay it's
a very loose definition but is there
anything with that definition more evil
than just like social media and when
when the algorithm gets you and starts
feeding you and it's not accidental it's
not just the the the cliche of the 60s I
I I probably you know uh idolize the 60s
too much but like you go to a happening
and you meet somebody and there's a book
on a shelf and all these weird
synchronicities now there really is math
and data being crunched I see we all see
it you know I click on the wrong guy or
I'm not saying the wrong guy I'm just
saying like a different kind of guy on
YouTube you know I started eating meat
and part of it is is YouTube uhhuh
that's [__] nuts and I say that
without shame but with humility meaning
I'm like we are receiving information
authority figures and things are
shifting who we are and when I let these
sort of like circus you know those balls
like MTV News that have all the letters
on it it's just like a borg like metal
of everything and it just start and like
of course it changes me well that's this
and the part what might be the scariest
part is it's actually not malignant it's
random it's it it's it's on its own no
it doesn't know it's also like here's a
speedr running video it doesn't have an
agenda own mathematical kind of thing
and we are being served it will like you
no matter what as long as you're seeing
the ad that's right and you will you
will slide down the ideological mud
slide without even knowing you're going
downward that's exactly what I'm saying
and and I we don't have to talk about
meat I just just was like isn't that
interesting that I think of myself as a
thing and I'm like but look and that's
why it helps me a little bit with
compassion I've tried to make this point
before but if you and I
lived you could use the ancient Greeks
everybody is bisexual it seems
everybody's different values you you
would have done those values right right
in the same way if you and I lived in I
don't want to say a place we would own a
gun mhm or we would we would hunt if
everyone I knew did this or did that or
you could say the other way just as
easily if the entire world was vegan and
killing an animal was just like
murdering somebody would all be vegan
you know what I mean well then how do
you account for
um the abolition movement how do we
account for people that buck the uh the
what we perceive as IM immoral uh uh
mores of our of our time to become
revolutionaries like that's an
interesting question you know I always
think like oh I would be if I lived in
the south in uh in the time of slavery I
would have been an abolitionist I have
no idea what what would have stirred my
soul to be righteous or to be complicit
in such evil right no I I I completely
agree and there are these outlying
movements and that's uniquely human I
think about again Terence mckenny goes
find the others it's like you're on this
conveyor belt he uses the conveyor belt
image too and it's like you go to school
you go to university you get a a wife
you get or a husband and you get a job
you have kids and then you die and
there's this image of like the people
that jump off the conveyor belt and
start running outside and there's like a
search light finding them it's like
that's a pretty good image of like
what's what's going on yeah obviously
what I'm doing is I'm not that iconic
clastic and I'm not that of an
outlier
externally and you know honestly I I
haven't even put this together out loud
but it's like it's because I don't want
the trouble I I want everything to be as
even as I can so that in side it can be
as uneven as as wild and crazy as I want
to be inside you're saying that your
external it's like why not be why not be
Polly yeah I completely understand you I
don't want 15 girlfriends yeah yeah
because that becomes my life it's like
putting my finger in the in the in the
wall with the leaks I'm like I don't
want to spend my time negotiating the
politics of 15 girlfriends even if I can
understand how like cosmically that
would make sense or whatever I'm like I
like paying taxes doing shows paying my
bills having a child being a dad being a
husband but that seems so square but I'm
like do you know how much time that
frees me up I don't want to be in the
Rave scene and and oh now I gotta F it's
like Louie Scandal noted Louie has that
great joke about Anderson Louie Anderson
Scandal
noted Lou CK has a joke about like I
don't want to smoke pot cuz I don't want
another thing uhhuh like I you're
leaving the house keys wallet phone Vape
I just don't want another [__] thing
and that's how I feel about almost
everything I'm like that's just another
even sometimes people I'm like look I
love people I like even meeting new
people but at a certain point you're
like I don't want another person to
reply to your text I'm trying to clean
it up even even people I don't want I
don't want 50 friends it's funny I'm the
opposite end of that not the friend
thing of Louis bit Scandal noted uh is
that I you know I'm still uh on nicotine
I'm chewing it right now and I know a
big part of why I don't want to give it
up cuz you do want a thing I want one
thing I don't want no things MOSI kosi I
don't want zero
things I have gone off nicotine yeah and
I've gone off coffee and then I was like
I'm not there yet meaning I go to bed
Norman Le said this when he was on the
podcast he's like I go to bed with the
taste of tomorrow's coffee in my mouth
and I go to bed I have my coffee a
couple hours after I've been up and then
I have my first nicotine after my first
meal so but I love going like there's a
a little thing coming oh yeah it's just
and and it's it goes back to the addict
it's like you want to you want to be
addicted to something well here's
something benign you can be addicted
well that is that that idea of of that I
think Alan Carr talks about and how to
stop smoking that like I I've never read
it and that's why I'm still stop smoking
the easy way yeah I've never read it and
that's why I'm still on these nicotine
pods but the idea is but it wouldn't you
didn't listen how stop sucking you
wouldn't listen you didn't listen to the
NPR about that I did hear it and it was
very funny to me but you know what those
kind by the way because the data has
changed because there's this whole
smokeless nicotine like life hack group
and that book which is great and has
helped so many people its whole premise
is like you're getting nothing from this
and they're like but nicotine but you
are getting something from it shoots
your dopamine and all these things this
comes back to a point that I was trying
to make earlier in our conversation that
I want to make sure I I I fall I double
back on which is I wrote this whole
story about my time in AA and it was the
big it was by far it was my church for
you you mean in subculture vulture
that's correct available right now from
random house question um it was my my
church for you it was uh it it was my
defining Young let's finish this and and
then I had a very slow and I mean I
cannot give to you Pete like when it
comes to Judaism which is also one of
the sections in the book Judaism I am I
carry Judaism uh with such a uh loose
garment kind of relationship with it I
love it but it doesn't I don't feel
guilty when I don't do it I don't it's
just like it's ease and I because I've
never had the experience of being a
fundamentalist and when it came to AA I
did have the experience of being a
fundamentalist it wasn't so much fire
and brimstone but it was definitely
fundamentalism this is all true and one
day you know 20 years into it or
something I started to go I don't know
if I I don't know how much of this feels
true to me anymore I was 15 years old
I'm a
permanent unchangeable alcoholic
hardcore no matter what for me to drink
is to die that doesn't feel that doesn't
feel intellectually honest to say I know
that for sure at 30 years old everything
else about me when I was 15 is
fundamentally and wildly different but I
know this one thing about me is
permanent all this stuff this little
thread and it's what we were talking
about at the beginning this idea that
maybe I need to move past this
fundamentalism which gave me this when I
did the spiritual work about that I I'll
tell a short side scary what it was very
scary and I didn't even see it coming
what happened was I was about what's
that yeah I was about 15 years sober and
I was very stuck in judgment I was the
king of young people's AA in in in the
Bay Area I was the the guy and I was the
sheriff I would come to you and I would
go Pete you know we don't do that here
or whatever you know like that was my
thing and I started very similar to
church yes right I the new convert and
the young convert oh the new con nothing
worse than the new convert nothing worse
than oh just the worst two years in two
years in Burning Man AA I'm sure Church
Judaism two years in let's not talk for
another 6 years come on back to me when
you have some doubts right so good so I
this my best friend who I'd grown up
with since I was TW the first the guy
that said hey are those camel W you want
to come get high with me he had gotten
sober and we had been sober get I've
known this guy since I was 12 I went I
mean everything I did I did with him and
he had been dating this girl um Brent
wbach and it was not Brent Weinbach this
is an older friend than that and he'd
been dating this girl who was N9 months
sober um and that's against Sheriff
Mosa's rules of how to operate not to
date another a young a person that's not
sober for a year that's that's hardcore
against the rules and he'd been dating
her for 6 months now she was a year and
two change sober and I found out and I
said why didn't you tell me you were
dating somebody yes and he goes well I
was afraid of what you would say buddy
guess who's hard relating a friend of
mine um they they terminated a pregnancy
and I was like why didn't you that must
have been so emotionally you know rot
and I'm your friend he's like I didn't
want you to judge me yeah I was like the
worst like a like a a tumble weed
rolling through your labyrinth exactly
and I said I had this like moment just
what that face that was that was I go oh
my God my adherence to this thing that I
think is bringing meaning to people is
actually causing the people that I love
to not ever get close to me because
they're scared of me so I went went to
this new AA sponsor guy and I said I
want help he was a much more of a weirdo
uh like kind of Yi and he wasn't old
school conservative AA and I kind of
maybe a raw bellish person within the
framework of the analogy we're making
church to church right yeah yeah and I
went to cuz I had before that been like
APC Pastor doing dabs for Christ you
know like like cool on the outside but
like fire and brimstone on the inside
user then a who Wast and I said help me
become softer I don't know what to do my
judgment is pushing people away and he
said to me what would it be like and
this is a long time ago but he said to
me what would it be like if you stopped
commenting on other people's behavior
alt together and I'm not kidding Pete I
had a physical reaction like I like it
was like people will die like if I'm not
there if the sheriff isn't there the the
world will fall apart into Anarchy well
people will I like I was I physically
was panicking and so I started this
process with him it's a great uh BJ
Novak joke where he goes sometimes I'm
on an airplane I turn to my the guy next
to me it's totally fake obviously and he
just goes do you think I can crash to
this plane just by thinking about
it and I think about that joke all the
time cuz that's how we are yeah we think
we're keeping the plane out we 100% it
is all illusion but we you know human
human greatness and stuff is real and it
does affect people but I'm not
responsible for everyone's well-being
but I didn't know that so I started this
process of um I'm going to stop and
here's how it would work here's how the
process would work for a while I would
see something wrong in a meeting I would
go to say it I would look over at my
soft sponsor who would like shake his
head across the room at me no I would
fite it back and I would go [__] he's
he's dead okay well he's not he's dead
[__] him you know it's like he's dead
he'll die and I that that's his problem
a little while would go they don't die
well I didn't yes I a time goes on and I
would see the behavior I would judge the
behavior i' think he's going to die but
it wouldn't fight its way out I wouldn't
beat it back and I would just stay
silent and go that's on you buddy you
are a dead man walking but I'm not
saying nothing and a little while would
go by would a little while went on and I
and I would look at the behavior and I I
not only wouldn't Not only would I not
have to fight it back I realized I
didn't think it was wrong anymore that
that I it was no longer I had somehow
shifted my reality so much that the
thing that was a sin it just felt like
Chris for the mill right and and that
was like freeing like a parent like you
know unnamed child is going to have hard
times and you're going to know like I
know your first partner seems like this
you want to explain it to them but
you're like touch the stove it's like a
touch the stove exactly it's not even a
sin anymore it's just what you're doing
and it has nothing to do with me uh my
soft sponsor describes it as going from
isn't that awful to isn't that
interesting and that was the sort of the
shift that I had had and that was
awesome that was so freeing I was in a
bondage that I couldn't feel because I
had fashioned the chains and then when I
loosed the chain I was like light and
free but something odd happened as a
result of losing the chains modern
mammals is the best
Shimp I'm sorry sports center but
something happened which is that by
taking away one of the fundamentals of
this uh expansive quilt that I had
knitted of Truth it became this little
thread that I started to tug on and I
was free and I was feeling freedom and
good and then all of a sudden the thread
became a bigger and bigger hole in the
reality that I thought that I understood
the problem with fundamentalism is that
if some of it isn't true anymore it's
possible that none of it's true and that
was the space that I found myself in it
took many years of me slowly coming to
this realization that the 12 steps I I
love them and I still live my life by
the principles that I found in there it
Judaism has 6113 spiritual laws there
are laws governing every single every
single behavior when you go to the
bathroom you come out you say blessing
when you cut bread you say you eat bread
you say a blessing when you see I mean
everything and I think it's a very
powerful and beautiful system but it's
too complex for me 12 it's not very
chill it is not chill no one has ever
accused my people of being chill that is
not one of our primary blessing that
bread slicing chill that's very very
chill Christians have that too I'm going
to cast The Demon out of this chair
before I sit down uhhuh we have that
interesting that does sound chill that's
very I did it I didn't do it to your
chair sorry oh it's here oh no you
invited the demon to speak to you today
go into that J so I so I had this really
slow motion and I really I describe it
in the book as it felt very similar to
what I imagine it would be like to be an
elder in a church and realize one day
that you don't believe in God anymore
and you go what do I do I'm I'm
terrified if I tell the truth about
myself your whole life goes away it all
goes away and not only does my physical
life my wife my friends my church leave
me but have to admit the reality which
is really scary and chaotic which is
inside of this belief system things are
very orderly and and I really have the
answers and and I don't think I have the
answers anymore well you were you were
you were in the garden of geane you were
going I'm about to be crucified
interesting and you're like there's
nothing I can do and isn't that why
that's such a powerful symbol your
friends sell you out it's like I
remember seeing this video boy it was a
long time ago but he was like my
meditation practice is I'm on a River
going towards God and on the shore is
everything in my life and I'm just
waving goodbye to it and I I saw that
way before I was ready to even think
about that I was like that is what it is
it's like none of it comes with you and
then ultimately mosha on the shore too
yeah isn't that wild so you're doing
something very sacred you're reminding
me of this guy this guy Lord who is a
just an a true one-of-a-kind person in
AA in the Bay area covered in he looked
like Skeletor
yes in ba covered in in skeleton tattoos
on his face like one of the most intense
looking guys ever and he used to say
there came a certain point in my life in
recovery where I had to stop backing
away from a bottle and turn around and
start walking toward God and that to me
was the choice was like I was so scared
of what it would mean to let go of my
identity as a person in this uh Universe
not only because it there's messaging in
the program that if You' go away you're
you're going to drink again and if you
drink again to drink is to die and that
you will be miserable if you if you stay
sober you'll be a dry drunk and be a
miserable person not only that uh but
also because my friends would judge me
and my identity would be gone and the
thing that I said I am a you know I a
woman I am a Christian I am an American
I'm a Jew I if I let go of that what am
I and I couldn't let fear determine that
large of a decision and so I made this
very slow extraction um it's so I'm not
trying I'm not I'm decidedly not not
saying AA is a cult so nobody put that
in my face I'm saying there's a
similarity if you leave the cult you'll
become I just watched a great cult
documentary but is that sort of like
don't leave don't leave don't leave it's
one of the hardest things in the world
and so so when I was writing exactly
when I was writing this book I felt a
real self-consciousness because not only
do I have some thought conditioning but
I also truly believe that for a lot of
people 12st steps and AA are powerful
medicine powerful medicine that can help
them that really works I really do think
that it works for people I used to think
it was the only thing that would work
for people but I know that it does work
for people it worked for me it saved my
life and I'm still living my life
according to the principles that I lived
in it but I was really scared that by
writing this book and describing in
Frank terms subculture vulture available
now Random House describing in Frank
terms what happened to me and and where
I'm at now that I would be putting
people who read it at risk of you know
unraveling their own quilt and then I
had to realize just like I'm not
responsible for people in the meeting
behaving correctly I'm also not
responsible for somebody else's like
sobriety Journey like I'm just talking
about my own it's Fierce you're just
acknowledging that what you've written
is fierce I guess doesn't mean bad yeah
when I I Love A Course in Miracles and I
read I'm like this is like heavy metal
this is like really not gentle at all
interes and you're doing something
fierce but that's really powerful so a
couple things came up in breathing
underwater Richard Ro's book about the
12 steps that I love he says we're all
addicts we're addicted to our own way of
thinking I love that and so he's like I
don't care if you're an alcoholic the 12
Steps apply to you and here you are
saying here's a way of thinking that
maybe became an addiction just for you
yes 100% And then the Romas thing that
he used to get in trouble for um not in
the way that we say trouble now like
canceled and all big Scandal he just
means people didn't like it you know in
the old days uhhuh oh people just like
an idea challeng it but wouldn't you
know cut off his face um but he and I
quote it all the time but he's like you
don't want to be Jewish you want to be
free you don't want to be in the program
you want to be free you don't even want
to be sober you want to be free and I
don't want to be a Christian I don't
want to be this I don't want to be you
want to be free yeah so maybe you'll
enjoy this he also says all methods are
trapped so AA is a method but so is
everything beautiful and wonderful right
he goes and the last step is to destroy
the the method yeah and ran Mahari says
that too he's like the method let's take
AA out of it let's say it's Christianity
you're stoking the fire of your being
and you're using the method to get the
fire bigger yeah he goes and the last
step is when you're making fire you
throw the stick that you've been poking
it in Into the Fire meaning it all has
to go that's what I mean by fierce but
what you're saying to me I haven't read
it yet but like that sounds very in line
with these Fierce ideas that let's be
honest people don't like nobody on the
you're like a guy on the fourth of July
saying America doesn't exist like look
at it or or we founded in sin or even
worse you could do that but like it's
even more extreme to say
like you know when you drive between
states there's no line you're like it's
just an idea like wake up so that is and
I that is when we get to the to the
lament like yes I agree with everything
that that you're saying and a big part
of this of this book is me in these
worlds traveling through the I do each
segment is a history is a comedic
history of the the it's not just a
memoir it's also a history um Oakland
Judaism I yeah the a hat I never quite
understood what it's doing in there but
yes it's Judaism I like it because
you're about to put on your hats like
you put on your throwing one hat off and
putting on another which is what I did
which is what I did I you know as you
know I would my my my summer vacation
was flying from Oakland where I was a
secular Oakland Public School kid with
no religious life whatsoever and
throwing off my a cap and putting on a
yamaka and pretending to be a hdic Jew
for 6 weeks a year yeah all the most
interesting people are those double live
[__] I mean you know you say
about you know Judaism and oh I I envy
you for this identity and blah blah blah
but the truth is my identity is both
profoundly more Jewish than probably
almost any of the Jews you know and
profoundly less Jewish than all of the
Jews you know because I only did a
hyperart I was like um waterboarded um
uh pre pre-war Judaism 6 weeks a year
and then I would come home and be a
regular kid so I I couldn't read Hebrew
but I uh did know how to greet you in
Yiddish like I I mean there's a story in
the book when I couldn't read Hebrew and
it was coming up on my bar mitzvah and
uh I couldn't read Hebrew I mean he I
couldn't read the alphabet you're
supposed to be reading the Torah
everybody in the neighborhood spoke yish
as a first language I didn't know the
Hebrew alphabet and this local Rabbi in
uh on my summer vacation Rabbi misel uh
very nice guy he said to my dad he could
see I was struggling and he said to my
dad like give him to me and I'll teach
him Hebrew and this was like in the
early 90s where you could you know ask
for some alone time with a child it'd be
handed over no questions asked right so
I went to his house and every week I
would do the alphabet with the ABCs with
the local community rap it's like a
tamic scholar teaching me the ABCs it's
like Alan Turing teaching you the times
taes like that's the level of of of and
it was very kind yeah it is kind and
passionate of him and I was struggling I
couldn't do it too bad you were wasting
it on such a stupid language wait is
that is that a broken and useless
pointless Lang how did you become a keer
elf too bad you were wasting it on such
a useless language let's go make some y
fudge or as they call it in the Hispanic
Community the fudge the fudge so I'm
sitting there being taught to ABCs by
this guy in Pre for my bar mitz I'm like
I don't know 11 years old and he can see
him struggling and he goes he goes don't
worry don't worry hold on hold on shly
come in and he calls his oldest son
schully who comes in and he goes he goes
say the American alphabet we're in
Brooklyn yeah this kid was born in
Brooklyn by the way this is born in
America kid he goes say American
alphabet and schi goes oh no uh a
b d g and then the RAB body like claps
me on the back he's like look he is
stupid in English you are stupid in
Hebrew everybody's stupid isn't that a
beautiful
story what a [__] mench this guy was
that's the definition of a
mench I have to go okay
listen I I knew I always book a
lunch on the dumbest guests but wait
what meaning meaning you're a three-hour
episode
easy but here we are at a peak note you
close on such a great laugh I feel good
do you feel good yes yes what I want to
just close my thought here and say and
this will be the end that these are the
universes that I spent my life in and
these are what you were talking about
with the fire you know it's like sedara
thing I mean I never I have not reached
Enlightenment or even close to it but I
realize now having written this book and
looking back like yes each one of these
was a coat that I tried on each one of
these was an identity that I clung to
but each one of them is a universe that
have made up the building blocks of who
I am and I love them I love these world
so much I love AA I love burning man I
love the Rave world I I love deafness
all of these created me in the hip-hop
way what deafness yes def de you know
that my mom um do you know that you want
to hear an early joke of mine I know you
got a lunch this is one of my first
standup jokes very stupid can't wait
well the truth is my mom um even though
she's never been able to hear my comedy
has always been a huge fan of me doing
it and really supportive in fact some of
my early open mics Pete she used to come
to my shows and she would sit outside of
the shows and she would sell homemade
preserves that she'd made to support me
going on the road and keep me in the
world and well the truth is Pete they
became popular they became their own
kind of they kind of had a life of their
own and you've you've heard of uh Dev
Jam Comedy Jam yeah
[Laughter]
yeah all right I think we could probably
wrap it there I don't mind it I don't
mind it at all I don't mind it at all
what a treat you are just a gift a true
gift oh thank you Pete I it was I we
went in places I didn't expect and I
loved every everyone that we discovered
so we plinked we definitely plinked we
definitely we rippled our lives
and and thank you for everybody for
listening check out subculture vulture a
memoir in six scenes by mosha Casher and
the Ry Casher mosha Adolf Hitler Casher
uh I love you I love you too uh would
you say keep it crispy oh yeah I think
you should all keep it crispy will you
do it in the voice oh yeah I can do that
hold
on hello if there's one thing I want to
impress it's that youu should not do any
interracial dating but if there are two
things I want to impress upon you it's
that you should keep
[Music]
it thank you mhi good day good day to
you
sir yeah you made it win you made it win
you made it win oh yeah you made it you
made it you made it win oh yeah you made
it you made it you made it all yeah